[Music]
welcome back to cbs this morning a
georgia sheriff's deputy is out of a job
after beating a suspect during a traffic
stop
that was all caught on video we have to
tell you it is very tough to watch
it shows a deputy repeatedly punching a
black man named his name is roderick
walker as you see he's on the ground
this happened friday in clayton county
just south of atlanta
now the sheriff's office says no need to
show you the rest of the video you get
the point the sheriff's office says a
fire deputy
who has not been identified used
excessive force
walker's attorney says one firing is not
enough
mark straussman is in jonesboro georgia
that's outside the jail where walker is
now being held
so mark here's a question he was a
passenger in the car so why is he in
jail
now well it's a good question gail it's
it's not exactly clear but
he is in jail this jail behind me at the
clayton county jail he was arrested
after sheriff's deputies beat him up and
brought walker's
lawyer says the arrest itself was
unconstitutional
and walker's family is in shock
[Music]
that's the voice of roderick walker's
girlfriend juanita davis
as she watched clayton county sheriff's
deputies pin him to the ground
the video shows one deputy punching
walker in the face
several times that deputy is heard
saying walker
bit his hand walker's attorney says
his client denies he bit anyone i
honestly didn't think that
he was going to make it through because
the beating was so brutal
davis says she and walker were getting a
ride home after returning a rental car
friday
when the car they were in was pulled
over for an alleged broken taillight
walker was sitting up front on the
passenger side
davis says police approached walker
first not
the driver he was like do you have your
id yes or no
and roger's like no sorry i don't have
my id then he said okay get out the car
get out of the car
that part of the encounter was not
caught on camera and police have not
explained what happened next
minutes later walker was on the ground
pinned under two sheriff's deputies
his girlfriend screaming at police
her son cried out the back window of the
car
davis says the boy is now traumatized he
can't sleep through
night he wakes up crying he keeps asking
where's rodri
why did this happen to him walker was
arrested on two counts of obstructing or
hindering police
and two counts of battery according to
the sheriff's office
he has not been able to get out on bond
because of outstanding warrants
unrelated to the incident the sheriff's
office says walker has received medical
treatment
in jail but walker's attorney is
concerned he says his client lost
consciousness
at least twice during the beating and
his mouth continues to bleed
behind bars this was about the typical
your tail light is broken so we can stop
it this method of using this tactic
to get around your constitutional rights
needs to stop
now the clayton county sheriff's office
did not return our calls for comment it
has also
not released the incident report in a
statement the sheriff said he's turned
over this case
to county prosecutors anthony this one
has all the elements
of here we go again yeah yeah all right
mark thank you
you're right mark straussman here we go
again listen i know the story is still
unfolding
there's still a lot we don't know but
what we do see is very triggering we see
the woman reacting that you're hurting
him we see another
another child of color who was
traumatized clearly by what they saw
and that's why these things are always
very triggering so you have that story
then you have the story that we had
earlier the two sheriff's deputies
were ambushed that is definitely not
okay either and you have two extremes i
feel it's such a volatile time in the
country
it's very very very frightening too it's
not okay to shoot police who were just
sitting in their car
not okay the big question here is why
did
this man was a passenger why did they
even ask for his idea exactly right
a lot of answers to come there we hope